let's do something we used to do to get
our minds off of Donald Trump just for a
moment let's get to some old-fashioned
crazy advice on how to deal with demons
from televangelist Pat Robertson on the
700 club it's been too long since we've
done this and I want to do it on the Pat
Robertson 700 club a viewer wrote in and
again we assume that these are real
questions but who really knows asking
Pat for advice on behalf of a friend who
bought a house that she believes is
haunted sure my friend has the house
it's not me anyway here's Pat
Robertson's sage advice for this woman
Margaret says two years ago a born-again
single lady I know bought a 60 year old
house earlier this year she was woken up
by her bed shaking it happened again
then after asking neighbors if something
bad happened in the house she learned
there have been two separate suicides in
the garage and maybe a third in the
house a few others a few other things
have happened in the house like cabinet
doors being open that had been shot and
waking up to a unintelligible electronic
voice what do you suggest she do so
one word sell and get out you know there
are demon spirits they are real and I do
think that in this case the house is
possessed you could get a group of
people in there and do a exorcism and
get rid of them but I think in your case
the older ladies dinner sixties single
lady sell the thing let somebody else
have the problem the music that starts
during Pat's advice is just too much so
first he doesn't even understand the
question he says the woman is 60 years
old no the house is 60 years old the
woman didn't say anything about her age
but I like how in in some cases Pat
Robertson would recommend an exorcism
but based on what he understands to be
the particulars of this case he would
recommend a sale just what Jesus would
do Pat pawned the demonic spirits off on
some unwitting next homeowner well the
Bible tells you to love your neighbor
right
they move into your own house they're
not your neighbor anymore when I heard
electronic voices in a shaking garage I
thought there's a party next door this
isn't demonic possession it's just the
kids next door are throwing a big rager
those are some weak examples - I mean
cabinet doors being left open when you
thought you shot them right maybe series
just going off in our bedroom I don't
know he's called many things demonic in
the past including feng shui Ouija
boards yoga karate horoscopes Twilight
paintings of Buddha television shows
about ghosts Halloween psychics girls
levitating their friends at sleepovers
and sometimes even adopted children from
other countries could be demonically
possessed you know in the horrible times
of Donald Trump this sort of
old-fashioned insanity seems kind of
quaint in some way I don't know about
you